but in a hundred ships are still
standing by outside the Panama Canal
even though wait times to cross the
canal have been slowly improving each
day
an unprecedented drought has reduced
water levels forcing authorities to cut
down on the number of daily Crossings
and to impose weight restrictions on
ships slowing down operations at this
key trade artery that unites two oceans
but depends on fresh water to function
up in the Canal's operation can quickly
Ripple through the global economy as
shipping prices increase for each day
these vessels spend out here at Sea
waiting for a spot to cross
some ship owners have opted for
alternative routes increasing costs
shipping experts say this is another
Grim sign for a global economy under
pressure by many supply chain challenges
mostly related to a changing climate his
Warrior is a wake-up call for for us I
think the the the project to provide
more water to the Panama Canal is
something that is on the table in this
moment
yet that could take years to happen in
the meantime Less business means less
revenue for the canal and higher prices
for consumers the Canal's Authority says
the restrictions will cost them at least
200 million dollars in Lost Revenue in
the next fiscal year while prices have
been going up for ships waiting in line
each additional day can cost between 20
to 45
000 more depending on the size of the
ship skipping the line buying a slot in
special auctions organized daily by the
canal can now cost up to nine hundred
thousand dollars from an average of four
hundred thousand and finally the maximum
allowed draft means that larger ships
now need to send some of their cargo on
land spending hundreds of thousands of
dollars more to use trucks and trains
experts say it's too early to estimate
how much of this added costs will
translate into higher prices but that
they definitely will
but lifting current restrictions will
not be possible until sufficient rain
returns if they don't do this we're not
going to be able to attend any more
ships we're going to have to restrict
the draft more
and you have to understand that it's not
only the canal the water is also for the
human consumption in Panama City a
difficult balance that will require
costly infrastructure changes to
maintain the canal viable in a future
with more frequent and extreme weather
conditions Alessandro Al Jazeera Panama
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera